the Superboy of course the clone is
under our telepathic control and as
ordered turned against his would-be
liberators the three are contained and
we don't believe the league knows
they're here hey everybody we have to
freak out about this
Titans just dropped another preview of
Hawk and Dove so the doing Hank and Dawn
from the comics which is what most
people know them as there been a couple
different versions of the team so I'll
try to explain that and what they're
doing with the series based on the
costumes that we've seen so far there's
also a lot of talk about how they're
going to handle the Superman mythos and
I really do honestly think that they'll
go with Conner Kent Superboy just
because he's the easiest slam dunk and
none of the other TV shows seem like
they're gonna do him even the Supergirl
TV show seems like it's veering away
from Conner Kent Superboy which means
because he's such a popular character
it's probably because he's been
bookmarked for the future of Titans even
if we don't see him during season 1 but
it's the same people that make the
costumes for the other arrowverse shows
so like the new flash costume the new
version of the future flash costume is
made by the same person that made this
Robin costume that made these Hawk and
Dove costumes so if you're just finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything
as you've seen the last couple of weeks
they've been dropping more and more
Titans stuff so that's just gonna keep
building until they drop the first
trailer because they're filming the
first couple of episodes and there is a
new round of that flash ring giveaway
till I think of something better to give
away from my Titans videos you guys can
suggest whatever you want in the
comments somebody actually suggested
batarangs but we can figure that out
because it's gonna be a little while
before the actual Titan series premieres
but just look at these costumes and how
close they are to the comics now most of
what they're aesthetic is taking from is
starting with new 52 to rebirth comics
the most recent versions of the
characters were reintroduced with new
backstories during the new 52 I don't
think that they've come back during the
rebirth comics yet there's still a lot
of deep cuts that they haven't brought
back because rebirth was kind of like
another soft reboot reintroducing a lot
of old Canon and old storylines that got
Rhett conned when the new 52 came out so
it gets a little confusing but the whole
aesthetic of the new 52 is that the
colors pop a little bit more and it's a
little more
our core I would call it brighter but
that kind of implies tone and it doesn't
seem like Titans is going to be lighter
in tone than a show like the flash which
is probably one of the brightest of all
the DC TV shows next to Supergirl
Supergirl is like one end of the
spectrum arrow is the most hardcore show
that they have Titan seems like it's
going to be even more hardcore because
it's gonna air on the DC streaming
service so that's why you have
characters like hawk and dub because
Hawk is hardcore and he's being played
by Aquaman from Smallville if you don't
remember him he actually crossed over
with Stephen Amell on a show that they
used to do called Blue Mountain State it
was a football show at a university it
was very early in Stephen amell's career
I made a couple of jokes about it in a
video I did a while ago so even though
Titan's hasn't even dropped yet a lot of
these shows shoot in Canada so the
actors have worked together on other
projects so there are always funny
moments of crossover then you have the
literal crossover stuff where you have
Smallville actors coming on to the new
DC TV shows like Erica Durance Lois Lane
from Smallville is now Cara's or Elle's
Kryptonian Mother
they actually recast that role too it
used to be a different actress early on
in that show Minka Kelly is the one
that's playing dawn Granger the Dove
character she's never been on any comic
book TV shows before if you're not sure
how their powers work is this really
cosmic thing I don't know how the TV
show is gonna address it it probably a
combination of CG and just practical
effects so what happens is is the Lords
of chaos and order grant them the
ability to transform into what you would
call like battle form they say their
names Hawk dove and it's sort of an auto
on situation so they don't have to climb
into their costumes one leg at a time
like normal heroes in the DC TV shows
but because Hawks power makes him grow
so angry Hulk style he needs dove to
balance him out she gives off this
radiant light force this sort of her
true astral form and it helps balance
him so that he doesn't go crazy and
cause a whole bunch of collateral damage
so if you were to see them fighting
criminals in an alley it would sort of
be like him going full berserker rage on
everyone IND of punching everyone then
turning to him until I get him to chill
out before he started punching all the
heroes - so just taking a look at their
IMDB page they're actually listed for
every
single episode this season all 13 so far
as far as we know there's gonna be 13
episodes of Titans
but even though we've heard about
characters like Donna Troy and it sounds
like brother blood is gonna be one of
the villains we don't know how many
episodes every single character is going
to be in besides the main cast but it
sounds like Hawk and Dove will also be
main cast
but even though Hawk and Dove aren't
core Titans it'll be interesting to see
what their relationship with the team is
like maybe one of them like Dove works
with dick during the day maybe one of
them's at the police station it remains
to be seen how they're gonna tie these
characters together or if they'll just
run into each other after the Sun Goes
Down and they're all doing vigilante
work on the streets so just everybody
let me know what you think of this comic
book II looked at they're going with
with the more hardcore spin on what you
would think of of an arrow or a flash TV
show think about the flash if it was
done more in the tone of arrow just
darker grittier crime drama with a lot
of magic and a lot of mysticism because
of all the Raven
Trigon stuff that's going on Dick
Grayson Batman Lords where you get all
that crime drama you have alien outer
space things that are happening because
of Starfire then you have all your
demonology your magic through the Raven
character so it's almost like this show
does there's like every single thing
that you could do from the comics we got
aliens we have magic we have special
powers we have crazy comic-book costumes
so it's like they're turning the dials
up to 11 on every single thing for this
TV show I think they just really want
people to be jazzed up about it which
just seems like they are most of the
reaction when these pictures started
posting this morning was relatively
positive but we haven't seen the other
core Titans costumes yet so they're
probably just teasing this out slowly
building up to a footage reveal so if we
hear anything about when that's gonna
happen or if they make any confirmations
about when the series is gonna drop I'll
post a video about it
but they're still filming the first
couple of episodes like it's probably
gonna be the first four or five episodes
before they narrow in on what their
premiere date is gonna be I think they
just want to have enough episodes in the
can so that they don't run out before
they start airing them usually that's
how production works by the time arrow
and flash start airing episodes in
October
they're already busy filming say like
the seventh or eighth episode of the
season so they're going to be filming
Titan
right up until the beginning of the
summer then it's totally possible that
they could be ready to start airing
episodes in the spring because by the
time we get to April and May they'll be
about halfway through the season if not
almost done but there's a new round of
that flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
Titans related comment on the video
congratulations to Hamza Cu the winner
from the last video that I posted please
private message me so I can get your
contact details announce a new winner
when I post new DC you can click here to
learn all about Batman flashbacks on
Titans and you can click here for my
Robin preview video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight